so in order to understand the
pathophysiology of hypertension we do
need to think about how blood pressure
is related to cardiac output which is
represented by this q here
cardiac output or co
and peripheral resistance so if we have
greater peripheral resistance
and or greater a cardiac output we have
a higher blood pressure
cardiac output can be further divided
into stroke volume
and heart rate
as far as the factors that are involved
in cardiac output
so stroke volume is basically how much
blood is expelled by the heart
with each beat and the heart rate is how
fast the heart is beating
so that both of those determine both of
those are involved in determining the
cardiac output
so basically then blood pressure
is related to stroke volume heart rate
and resistance so if we increase any of
these values stroke volume heart rate or
resistance
that would increase blood pressure so
anything that
increases cardiac output which of course
is made up of stroke volume and heart
rate as we just saw
and or resistance if it increases
cardiac output or resistance
then we will increase the blood pressure
so
stroke volume is actually controlled
intrinsically and extrinsically
basically if you have a bigger heart and
you have longer muscle fibers
and your heart can contract more then
you can you'll have a higher stroke
volume
those are things that are intrinsic
extrinsic the sympathetic nervous system
will release epinephrine norepinephrine
onto beta adrenergic receptors of your
cells
and what those that those epinephrines
are hormone and norepinephrine is a
neurohormone
what those things do is they increase
the force of contraction
of your heart and what that hap what
that does is that
increases the stroke volume if it's
contracting with a greater force then it
can expel more
blood the heart rate can be controlled
parasympathetically and sympathetically
the parasympathetic nervous system
typically is the rest and digest
sympathetic as the fight or flight
it's a parasympathetic parasympathetic
you would expect it to lower the heart
rate
and sympathetic you would expect it to
increase the heart rate
by and the way it does that is
acetylcholine
is the is involved in the
parasympathetic
nervous system and the sympathetic
nervous system has epinephrine or
epinephrine
increasing the heart rate basically i'm
just trying to show you here what's
going on as a general idea as far as
if we increase these values or change
these values we're going to change the
blood pressure
one thing i do want to mention before i
go on is that the pathophysiology of
hypertension is still an active area of
research and not
everything is very well understood
specifically
genetics we know that family history is
important when we think about
hypertension so a family history is just
the idea that if your parents or your
grandparents have high
hypertension then you might be at a
higher risk for getting it
so this suggests an inheritance of some
sort
so although we don't understand this
very well
it is implicated that some genes seem to
be relevant there are
for instance there i remember reading
that mutations in
genes that code for proteins involved in
handling salt
by the kidneys
um could be a reason
for some people having a
higher sort of likelihood of getting
hypertension so maybe their kidneys
handle salt in such a way that
causes them to increase hypertension and
that
trait is herediable so like they can get
it from their parents and they got it
from their parents
so there is some sort of genetic uh
genetic basis for something we just
don't really understand it too well but
the autonomic nervous system is
something i was just mentioning the
parasympathetic and sympathetic nervous
system
so we know that sympathetic is the fight
or flight and parasympathetic is the
rest and digest
so if we have the autonomic nervous
system
and uh what would we expect the
autonomic nervous or
the sympathetic nervous system to do to
increase blood pressure if we want to
inc or if we're talking about
hypertension we're talking about an
increase in blood pressure or higher
blood pressure
so we would expect that the sympathetic
nervous system would have an increase in
activity that increase in activity
we would expect to increase the stroke
volume and and or
increase the heart rate and both of
these things would increase blood
pressure
another potential thing that could be
that can contribute to higher blood
pressure is
a decrease in activity of the
parasympathetic nervous system
so if there is a
the parasympathetic which is the
parasympathetic nervous system which is
supposed to
slow the heart rate down if that's not
happening
if there's a lack of decreasing the
heart rate due to inactivity of the
parasympathetic nervous system
that means we will have a higher heart
rate and a higher heart rate
will increase cardiac output and
increase the blood pressure
another thing is that stress stress
increases the activity of the
sympathetic
nervous system and what that can cause
is vasoconstriction so
vasoconstriction is the narrowing of the
blood vessels
and we know that pressure
is equal to force over area
so if we lower the surface area
let me put your surface area if we lower
the surface area
of the vessels by constricting them then
what we're doing is we're increasing
resistance and if we increase resistance
we're increasing blood pressure
so that's how the autonomic nervous
system could play a role
another thing is that that's pretty huge
is the renin-angiotensin aldosterone
system or the rast system
and basically the whole idea that
there's this thing called angiotensin ii
initially which is a very very potent
sort of
uh molecule that's involved or it's a
very
important component of this system here
basically the liver produces
angiotensinogen which is an inactive
form of angiotensin
so the kidneys produce renin
which causes antioxidant to become or
angiotensinogen to be converted into
angiotensin one
and angiotensin one can be turned into
angiotensin ii by this thing called
angiotensin converting enzyme which is
which comes from the lungs
and actually the kidney as well it comes
from the endothelial cells there
so what angiotensin to do does is it
increases sympathetic activity it
increases sodium and
chloride sodium and chloride retention
increases potassium excretion increases
water retention
increases aldosterone secretion from the
adrenal cortex
it increases arterial vasoconstriction
which of course
makes sense from this term angiotensin
and it also increases antidiuretic
hormone or
otherwise known as vasopressin secretion
now
the details of this can probably be
found elsewhere because
but the whole idea here is that an
increase in blood pressure is what
results from all of this
so what i really want to get at
is essentially that if there's a lot of
activity here if there's a lot of
production of angiotensin too
then we're going to have a higher blood
pressure so
a lot of activity here means a higher
blood pressure
so patients with high blood pressure
might have something going wrong with
this or maybe we're producing too much
angiotensin too
or too much renin too much ace whatever
it is
we're getting too much angiotensin too
and we're doing too much to increase the
blood pressure in a hypertensive patient
the last thing to be considered as far
as the pathophysiology
is the balance between vasodilators
and vasoconstrictors
so things that make the blood vessels
larger
or smaller so vasodilators
they decrease blood pressure whereas
vasoconstrictors
increase blood pressure so i've given a
few examples here
of some vasodilators and some
vasoconstrictors so
in the case of high blood pressure we
have too much
constriction too much of this perhaps
and not enough of this
so if the balance between these is off
then
um that could be the reason for or at
least off and in the favor
of the constrictors that we could have a
high blood pressure there
hope that video was helpful thank you
for watching